va avancer on va avancer avec avec de
voice de vol ce que buick est en colère
oui j'en connais puisque ils ont
remarqué que le jury cette année alors
moi je trouve qu'il est plutôt bien on a
dit ici on aime beaucoup de jeu et met
le public n'aime pas notamment notamment
les interventions de lara fabian
maram ans que ça agace ou bien faire un
petit regardez c'est toute une chanson
qui la chante presque tous les jours de
ma vie encore cette chanson là c'est un
vortex pouvoir mélanger l'âme de la
soprano à l'intérieur du contre-ténor
que tu es savez le colibri dans la voix
suffisent ce soir même si c'est un
garçon qui chante moi je les ai entendus
ce colibri et je les ai entendus en plus
avec une petite fêlure et qui moi m'a
permis vraiment d'être ému plusieurs
fois vous m'avez totalement totalement
séduite le seul univers auquel je crois
vraiment c'est celui qui nous unit dans
une pensée qui nous divise plus et le
césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué à
le jury le jury cette année pour moi
c'est insupportable
lara fabian pour moi les autant
incompétente que laisser finir qu'il
faut excuser moi tu en paies de mots je
vais dire insupportable supportable est
absente
marc lavoine il fait tout plein la
gueule et l'air dépressive
il fait tout le temps la gueule et voilà
y est voilà et heureusement qu'il ya
pascal obispo et amel bent pour lever
les programmes parce que franchement
c'est la mayonnaise est compensée par
contre je trouve c'est un jury mais
d'une générosité
ici vivent ils sont ils sont émus ils
pleurent et rient ils prennent des
leçons pékin li dan cooper etc
excusez moi ils donnent énormément leur
à fabian a invité une candidate perdante
à son va faire sa première partie fin
moi je les trouve d'une générosité
incroyable
le seul problème c'est ils font des
choix très bizarre et j'en ai marre
d'une unis à la forme y aller je tendis
des choix il attendait la perelle la
saisir c'est vrai qu'il ya sur les
réseaux il ya eu il ya un non choix du
jury qui ne s'est pas retourné sur une
candidate qui chantait à l'eau on va
avoir un beau la performance est bon
elles sont là le chante mais c'est ma
gueule sont pas de ouf
regardez
[Musique]
[Rires]
où
bourré ou mais une chance de vos trous
mais si on traitait 5
[Musique]
hu
mais
[Musique]
si le traité
j'adore
rue d'anjou s'est pas
si vous
[Applaudissements]
c'était pas jusque là mais même source
des voix que c'est pas ouf la non moi je
trouve sublime a fait des frissons c'est
chic entendre et je suis désolé je
trouve que lara fabian cette année c'est
un peu la tête de turc de tout le monde
des réseaux sociaux des gens méritent
aussi non non elle est passionnée c'est
une fille quand elle parle qui sont
qu'elle elle joue pas c'est une vraie
passionnée et moi je trouve c'est la
première année où ils ont réussi à
reconstituer un jury justement qui
accroche et qui fait parler parce qu'on
parle que d'eux
donc ce top 20 mois où je rejoins magali
et vous en même temps c'est le problème
de the voice c'est que les jules les
membres du jury en effet ils sont ils
sont bien ils sont dans leur rôle on
travaille fort jobs
lara alors on peut dire ce qu'on veut
mais pardonnez moi a une très belle voix
elle s'est s'exprimé donc à l'aune de
leçons de recevoir à personne surtout
pas de nous mais en revanche là où je
suis pas là j'ai aimé quand même un
doute c'est sur les candidats sont pas
non tenues c'est pas eu vol
pour l'instant je n'ai pas encore eu le
grand grand frisson mais là où j'aime et
une autre à notre doute c'est sur les
bancs du jury il se retourne pas sur sur
le monde et voir où on tournera
justement donc on va regarder ya une
prestation
une personne qui revêt chalot pas où on
a besoin alors regardez écoutez et après
on va voir si vous seriez retourner ou
pas c'est parti
[Musique]
à
mais
[Musique]
allez
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà bien évidemment je vais vous dire
c'est au riz mais d'abord la musique
c'est comme le rire c'est ultra
segmentant avant d'aller donner des
leçons aux jurys de dire pourquoi il se
retourne et se retourne pas bien pas ici
une personne qui va être d'accord avec
le même le même artiste qu'on verra mais
bien évidemment je me retourne pas pour
une simple raison elle est ultra
technique
c'est quelqu'un qui a pris des cours de
chant ça manque d'émotion ça manque de
frissons mais j'aimerais juste
j'aimerais juste revenir sur un point
parce que moi j'ai critiqué au départ le
jury il y en a une qui est moins qu'ils
aient moins sa place mais un prêt de
maturité c'est amel bent et on voit bien
que très souvent elle est un peu en
extase devant les devants les deux ans
que dit marc lavoine ou d'autres mais
lara fabian
on peut pas on veut pas entendre ça les
artistes ils viennent ils veulent ils
rêvent de devenir des stars
vous avez une émission où vous avez lara
fabian qui explique pourquoi elle n'a
pas retenu la personne et de manière
professionnelle et technique économique
attendue arrive pendant 25 minutes ça
donne qui a pas été choisie depuis des
mois c'est un peu mais attendez je n'en
ai pas ce sont des gens fragiles qui
sauf sur des gens qui ont entre 16 et 20
ans vous ne pas leur dire on va sur on
va sur une relation de deux vols ce la
bonne nouvelle c'est que comme on va
passer aux battles maintenant ils vont
changer enfin de costumes ça fait quand
même tourné disque on peut quand même
donner notre avis je vous en prie